you
you know more than any beauty editor so
please talk me through kind of you know
when you do your lingerie you said to me
I don't just think about myself I think
about the woman was gonna wear it was
that a similar approach to my course
well first and foremost what I really
wanted to create was a makeup range that
was built for the woman on the go every
day woman on the go versatile pieces
that were easy to use on the go I think
your wound looks to me like a really
good way to even for people who are
maybe scared of makeup to start building
a bit of a makeup makeup wardrobe and
what tips would you give like if you are
now going to go from this to tonight
what's kind of an easy cuz I think a lot
of girls especially in all of your
customers we were working women will
have kids and they're busy and you know
you have a beautiful day look and then
you want to just take like it take it
not what would you do or watch a combat
well I actually am a really big fan of
these cream eyeshadow sticks and they
are so good for the girl and go because
they just get thrown into your handbag I
mean look at this throw those in your
handbag and these are really really
buildable and so easy to use so you
could just rub it onto I like that and
you've got a sort of quite dark dramatic
eye or you could start to blend it out
with a brush or your finger and they're
kind of foolproof I mean you could
literally look gorgeous apply that on
the back of a tractor and you would end
up weather with a beautiful look and
they all work with each other that's the
other thing about the collection was I
wanted everything to work with each
other so somebody could come in by an
eye palette one week and a mascara and a
cheek palette and then come back a few
months later and add to their collection
and it would work for what they've
already got it's versatile and it's easy
to use and interchange so and feel so
luxurious there's a lot of talk now you
know especially with YouTube and
Instagram everything a lot of emphasis
on tools yes and there's good quality
there's you know it's hard to get good
quality brushes at a decent price talk
to me about how important it was in
which brushes are the ones that you are
really well we've started off with just
four brushes which was important to me
that we had brushes too that we could
use with the collection and they're
synthetic which is great
cruelty free and this is an eyeshadow
brush and so and this is just again
really easy to use I would also actually
use this I could even use it for powder
or anything underneath the eyes this of
course is a big bronzing brush I'll be
mine yes and that is can be used
actually all over the face and even all
over the body this brush which is great
for contouring sits the slanted brush
and you would use that was the cream you
could get I mean I like to use brushes
with cream I mean I I apply most of my
makeup with my hands because I'm kind of
always on the go but I would use this
for for blusher or wedges this one for
blusher and I choose this one for
contouring or even for powder under the
eyes and things like that
we've actually got four eyeshadow
palettes which is which is a fair amount
to start with this one is called um I
feel like a million dollars I named
everything and they're all kind of all
the names are sort of related to me in
some way and these colors actually were
inspired by one of the lingerie
collections a few seasons ago that I did
with Suzy Jenkinson and head of lingerie
I could see that literally as having
that you can do add a look you can do
anything you'll know exactly what's in
your handbag right now and my handbag
right now is my iPhone my passport
always in my handbag usually some form
of paperwork for something or other to
do with my day so my schedule and at the
moment or over the last couple of months
have been my five five minute products
I've had the samples I've been playing
around with those have just been able to
throw them in and that's what's been
keeping me keeping me going through the
day what was the last emoji you used I
think it's like the only emoji I use is
the laughing crying face you know you've
done something naughty again and what
were the last three songs you listen to
on your iPhone Adele yes hello Drake
hotline bling and I was just looking at
this before and Mozart as having a
massage and I like Mozart when I'm
having a massage yeah what was your best
and worst Valentine's gift my worst
Valentine's gift ever was from one of my
first boyfriends
he gave me a stack of the not they
weren't post-it notes but you know like
the kind of stack of notes that you keep
by the phone you tear them off a stack
of those with a pencil and a statue of a
unicorn really generous of him I really
really thought about that I think I
might picks it up in the quarter shelf
or something and the best Valentine's
gift I've ever received would be a pair
of vintage Art Deco earrings oh wow oh
wow okay I'm finished a sentence I would
Q of a night for it's not much of a Q
over night for I'm not going to lie for
I probably queue overnight for family or
friends that's about it well that's our
story yeah I would say this note there's
nothing that would get me out there's
not much just forgive me up bed to be
honest thank you so much yeah
you